Bienvenido a la presentación de
problemas avanzados de razones,
vamos a empezar con el siguiente problema.
Imagínate que tenemos un salón de clases
donde el total de estudiantes,
aquí le voy a poner,
el total es 57 y donde la razón de niñas a niños,
lo voy a escribir así "a" entre "b" es igual a 4 sobre 15...
a 4 sobre 15.
Hasta ahorita todo se ve muy normal,
pero lo interesante es la siguiente pregunta,
¿cuántos niños necesitan salir para que la nueva razón de niñas a niños sea ahora 4 entre 11?
Déjame escribir la pregunta por acá...
¿Cuántos niños...
cuántos
niños...
necesitan salir...
necesitan
salir
para que "a" entre "b"
para que la razón de niñas a niños,
"a" entre "b" sea igual a 4 sobre 11?
Muy bien, esta es la pregunta que
queremos responder y se ve fascinante.
Un primer paso que podemos hacer es encontrar el número de niños y de niñas
que hay en el salón y ya sabemos hacer eso porque hicimos un problema muy similar en el video anterior.
Entonces déjame reescribir
esta información como si,
si el total es 57 y "a" es la cantidad
de niñas y "b" es la cantidad de niños,
entonces "a" más "b"...
"a" más "b" es igual a 57.
Y si multiplicamos por "b" esta igualdad,
nos queda que "a" es igual a 4 sobre 15,
multiplicado por "b", de modo que podemos sustituir el
valor de "a" aquí arriba y obtener una ecuación en "b".
Vamos a hacer eso,
nos quedaría que 4 sobre 15
multiplicado por "b" más "b" es igual...
déjame hacer ese igual más bonito, es igual a 57.
"b" es 15 sobre 15,
entonces esta suma es 19 sobre 15,
nos queda que 19 sobre "15b" es igual a 57, multiplicando por 15 y dividiendo
entre 19, nos queda que "b" es igual a 57
multiplicado por 15 y dividido entre 19.
Y observa que 57 entre 19 es 3, esto de aquí es 3,
de modo que "b" es igual a 3 por 15, o sea 45.
Muy bien, esto nos da el número de niños,
de niños del salón
y sabemos que en total son 57 estudiantes,
de modo que la cantidad de niñas
es lo que falta para 57,
es decir, "a" es igual a 12, muy bien, esto nos da la cantidad de niñas y de niños en el salón.
Y otra forma de escribir que la razón "a" entre "b"
es 4 entre 15 es poner "a" entre "b"...
"a" entre "b", como 12 entre 45.
Esto es igual a 12 entre 45,
ahora en el problema se van a salir algunos niños
y nosotros queremos
que la nueva razón sea ahora 4 entre 11,
si...
4 entre 11...
Entonces
¿cómo le hacemos para plantear eso algebraicamente?
Aquí tenemos "a" entre "b", pero nosotros
no nos interesa "a" entre "b", sino nos interesa
que se salgan algunos niños...
déjame ponerle a esa cantidad,
a la cantidad de niños que se salen, "x",
vamos a pensar que salen...
salen...
"x", vale.
Entonces,
¿cuál sería la nueva razón?
¿cuál sería el nuevo valor, este,
de la razón de niñas entre niños?
Bueno, pues la cantidad de niñas
seguiría siendo "a",
pero tenemos que dividir entre
la nueva cantidad de niños, entre "b"...
"b" menos "x"...
si, se salieron "x"...
y sabemos que "a" es...
"a" es 12 y "b" es 45,
entonces la nueva razón sería
12 dividido entre 45 menos "x", va.
Si esto te confunde un poquito,
velo y medítalo con calma.
Simplemente estamos diciendo
que la cantidad de niñas se quedó igual
y que la cantidad de niños
disminuyó en "x", vale,
entonces esto sería la nueva razón
y la información que aquí nos dicen es que queremos que la nueva razón sea igual  a 4 dividido entre 11.
Y con esto ya podemos plantear
una ecuación en "x",
bueno es muy importante que veas
de donde salió esta expresión, sale.
Bueno, vamos a resolver ahora esta...
esta...
esta igualdad o bien, vamos a despejar "x"
multiplicando por 11, 11 por 12 es 132,
nos queda que 132 es igual a 4 por 45,
45 más 45 es 90, 90 más 90 = 180,
4 por "-x" es "-4x", de esta forma "-4x"...
a ver voy a tener que resolverlo aquí,
es igual a 132 menos 180 es -48...
-48, dividiendo entre -4
nos queda que "x" es igual...
es igual a 12
y esto lo que nos dice es que se tienen que salir
12 niños para que la razón sea 4 entre 11.
Y podemos verificarlo, vamos a ver si esto
tiene sentido, si se salen 12 niños,
entonces ahora la razón sería...
sería, la cantidad de niñas es igual,
sería 12 y tenemos que dividir entre 45 menos 12,
45 menos 12 es 33 y en efecto,
simplificando un 3,
nos queda 4, 4 dividido entre 11,
de modo que la respuesta
es que se tienen que salir 12 niños.
Muy bien, entonces parece un poco difícil
y aquí hay un poco de fracciones,
pero en realidad no es tan difícil verdad,
simplemente hay que plantear una ecuación
y meterle un poquito de álgebra.
Bueno, vamos a hacer otro problema.
Déjame bajar para tener un poco más de espacio.
Vamos a cambiar de color para que no sea tan
monótono, voy a hacerlo en naranja, sale.
Supongamos que tenemos una canasta de frutas
y sabemos que en esa canasta de frutas,
hay manzanas y plátanos y la razón de manzanas
entre plátanos es igual a 5 entre 19...
5 entre 19.
Y luego vamos a agregar 23 plátanos...
déjame poner una flechita y vamos a poner...
¿qué vamos a poner?
¿qué vamos a agregar?
Vamos a poner que vamos a poner...
eso suena divertido...
23 plátanos...
plátanos, vale.
Y sabemos que después de hacer esto,
la nueva proporción de manzanas a plátanos nos queda
10 entre 61,
¿cómo escribiríamos eso?
Bueno, pues la cantidad de manzanas permanece
igual y ahora la cantidad de plátanos,
son 23 más,
entonces manzanas entre plátanos más 23,
la nueva razón de manzanas a plátanos,
es igual a 10 entre 61...
10 entre 61...
Bueno, esta es la información que nos dan
y la pregunta es la siguiente,
la pregunta es, ¿cuál es la cantidad de fruta en la
canasta... le voy a poner así...
cantidad de fruta...
de fruta
en la canasta...
en la canasta
después de meter los plátanos...
los plátanos adicionales...
después
de meter...
de meter
los plátanos...
plátanos adicionales...
adicionales...
adicionales...?
Muy bien, esto de aquí es la pregunta.
Si te das cuenta, pues cuando plantee el problema,
ya di una sugerencia, porque ya escribí las
dos ecuaciones que necesitamos,
en la primera nos dice que la razón inicial de manzanas
a plátanos, es 5 entre 19
y después al agregar
23 plátanos nos dicen que es 10 entre 61,
pero aquí ya lo escribimos,
simplemente tenemos la misma cantidad de manzanas, pero ahora los plátanos aumentan en 23.
bueno, esto nos da dos ecuaciones,
tenemos dos variables,
así que podemos resolver este sistema.
Déjame despejar en ambos el valor de "m",
despejando en la primera nos queda que "m",
"m" es igual a 5 entre 19,
multiplicado por "p" y despejando "m" en la segunda,
nos queda que "m" es igual a "10p" más 23,
o sea sería "10p" más 230,
dividido entre 61... entre 61.
Esto lo podemos reescribir como
"10p" entre 61 más 230 entre 61
y aquí tenemos dos expresiones
para "m", por lo tanto son iguales,
así que podemos igualarlas,
podemos poner que 5 entre 19,
lo voy a poner de este lado,
5 entre 19 multiplicado por "p"
es igual a esta expresión de acá,
10 entre 61, multiplicado por "p" más 230,
230 entre 61.
Y aquí podríamos resolver este...
esta ecuación lineal pero hay muchas fracciones
y ya no me queda tanto tiempo,
así que... así que pues simplemente voy a poner
cual es el valor que nos debe quedar,
nos queda que "p" es igual a 38
y tú lo puedes verificar con calma en tu cuaderno.
Bueno, si tenemos que
la cantidad de plátanos es 38
y nos están diciendo, este que "m"
entre "p" es 5 entre 19, entonces "m",
de hecho lo podemos ver aquí,
la cantidad de manzanas es igual a 5
entre 19 multiplicado por 38,
que es igual a 10.
Muy bien, entonces al inicio tenemos 10 manzanas
y tenemos 38 plátanos,
entonces en total tenemos
48 piezas de fruta,
entonces tenemos 10 más 38,
que son 48,
pero luego agregamos 23 plátanos más 23,
entonces sería 48 más 23, que es 71
y de esta forma al final tenemos
71 piezas de fruta en la canasta,
vamos a hacer un breve repaso.
Nos dicen la razón inicial de manzanas a plátanos,
luego agregamos 23 plátanos,
las manzanas se quedan igual
y abajo nos queda plátanos más 23
y nos dicen que esto es 10 entre 61,
a partir de ahí podemos despejar el valor de "m"
en ambas igualdades,
obteniendo esta expresión y esta expresión,
luego los igualamos,
con eso podemos encontrar el valor de "p"
y teniendo el valor de "p"
ya es fácil encontrar el valor de "m",
los sumamos y recordamos
que se agregaron otros 23 plátanos.
Muy bien,
entonces la respuesta es 71
y me parece que con estos ejemplos
ya estás listo
para resolver por tu cuenta algunos problemas
avanzados de razones.